2018 is here and incredibly enough, the Earth's
core hasn't melted down yet.
Somehow, humanity has managed to survive several
extinction level events over the past few
weeks, including but not limited to, the republican
tax bill passing, net neutrality being repealed,
Russian bots trolling Twitter, and of course,
late night Trump Tweets.
While it's pretty clear the endless hysteria
about the return of the Nazis, the hyperbole
describing the end of the world and the general
lunacy of our collective social media hive
mind is going to continue into 2018 and beyond,
I want to look back, make my prediction and
offer a glimmer of hope in the madness.
In my first Direct Message of 2017, I had
said if 2016 was the year of fake outrage,
then 2017 would be the year of misguided anger.
Though I'm no Nostradamus, I think my prediction
came out looking pretty damn good.
My prediction was based on a few trends, but
primarily that if you spend all of 2016 saying
that Trump was Hitler, and he turned out not
to be Hitler, that you would've painted yourself
into an intellectual corner, which could only
come out in misguided anger.
Once you've labeled someone as Hitler, you
can't really walk your statement back by acknowledging
that they might occasionally do something
good.
This line of thinking was a trap that the
Left set for itself and is one of the reasons
I spent so much time in 2016 trying to reform
the Left.
The endless name calling and virtue signaling
was obviously going to lead to more misguided
anger if the prophecy of Trump as Hitler didn't
come true.
After all, you can never give a Hitler figure
credit if he does something good, so you just
have to endlessly double-down and slide further
and further to the extreme.
You may hate Trump's appointees, the Republican
tax plan and more, but you do have to face
that Hitler he is not.
To continue this line of thinking is to dishonor
the millions of people who died at the hands
of a fanatical madman.
The misguided anger which Trump's election
brought didn't just affect politicians and
pundits, but ordinary people, too.
Every single day I get dozens of emails from
regular folks who are losing friends, who
are ostrasized by their family members, or
most dangerously afraid to say what they think
because it may fall outside of the accepted
narrative.
News organizations from Buzzfeed to HuffPo
even to CNN and the NY Times, exposed themselves
as places of Leftists activism more than places
of honest and unbiased journalism.
While the 2016 election should've brought
some introspection amongst this class, it
instead brought a doubling down of attacking
anyone who steps outside of the accepted norms.
This dishonesty and desire to control what
you think is exactly what led to the rise
of the trolls, the meme makers and the frogs.
OK, on to 2018.
While there clearly will be no course correction
by those who trade in identity politics and
collectivism, I see many signs that their
movement is beginning to lose steam.
Of course if you were tracking this all along
you knew this was the inevitability of the
oppression olympics, if you believe victimhood
to be virtue, then you must be always be a
bigger victim than the person next to you.
This is the fatal flaw of intersectionality:
together you aren't stronger, you are actually
weaker because of your competing interests.
This is why leftism, collectivism, socialism
or whatever you want to call it has always
led to more authoritarian control and more
dead bodies in the name of tolerance.
It is a snake that eats its tail, and right
now if you look close enough, the snake is
about half way through with lunch.
While the snake eats, those of us who are
woke, as the kids say, are going to find allies
every which way we look.
Right before Christmas I spoke at the largest
gathering of conservative college students
ever, at Turning Point USA's annual conference
in Palm Springs.
Many former Rubin Report guests were there
including Ben Shapiro, Dennis Prager and Greg
Gutfeld.
During my speech I talked about being for
gay marriage, for a woman's right to choose
and a slew of other so-called liberal ideas.
The speech wasn't just warmly received, I
actually got a standing ovation for talking
about our differences and how we can find
common ground.
I'd be happy to do the same exact speech for
a progressive organization, but I won't hold
my breath waiting for the invitation.
While one side preaches tolerance but doesn't
actually practice it, I think 2018 is finally
going to be the year this script gets torn
up and rewritten.
If you truly stand for the individual and
believe we live in a free society where our
differences should be relished and not relinquished,
then you will find people to connect with
every direction -- just look at the diverse
voices who we had in this very studio who
caught fire in 2017, like Jordan Peterson,
Brett Weinstein, Lindsay Shepard, Laci Green,
Colin Moriarty and Yasmine Muhammed.
These people came from all across the physical
map as well as the ideological map, yet have
found common cause in fighting for their ability
to say and think what they believe.
So if 2016 was the year of Fake Outrage and
2017 was the Year of Misguided Anger, I believe
that 2018 will be the year of Unusual Alliances.
If you make the decision in your mind to be
for the only diversity that matters, the diversity
of thought, you will quickly find it easy
to find friends where you once found enemies.
And, as has happened to me on more than one
occasion, you might just change your mind
instead of changes someone elses.
It can be humbling and even scary when that
happens, but that's the risk of real diversity,
but I think it's one well worth taking.
My challenge to you is to do something this
year.
Don't just talk about it, do it.
Whatever that is to you.
Start fighting for your beliefs in the real
world, not just by using a hash tag on Twitter.
Even if you disagree with me on everything,
get out there and fight for whatever it is
you believe.
Obviously don't use violence or your right
to free speech to infringe on someone else's
right to use theirs, but stand up for the
ideas you care about.
The old systems of politics, media, Hollywood
and even sports are crumbling right before
our eyes and it's up to us to decide what
will come next.
I believe that we have a chance to build on
the ideas of classical liberalism, of libertarianism,
of individualism and of personal freedom instead
of authoritarianism, socialism leftism and
authoritarian control.
I will fight for those ideas like never before
in 2018 and I hope that you will join me,
whatever that means to you...